what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chain
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off David Kammerer is
the co-founder and CEO of crypto trader
tax in this conversation we discussed
the new tax guidance from the IRS why it
is so complex how cryptocurrencies are
becoming more difficult to report
through the legacy infrastructure
exchanges and how crypto trader tax is
helping clients quickly and accurately
report their acquired tax treatments I
really enjoyed this conversation and I
learned a lot I hope you enjoy it as
well
skirt school want to know who has the
best URL crypto comm that's right
crypto comm they're a crypto platform
with one goal mother and mass adoption
that's why we're all here
we're trying to get crypto in every
wallet crypto comm is helping people do
that through buying earning lending and
card payment everything you could want
at crypto comm go help your boy out tell
them pomp sense you download the app or
visit crypto comm pumps got you always
everyone to get into mining and didn't
know how don't worry your boy pops
gotcha everybody got some electricity
and Wi-Fi all you got to do is go to
coin mine comm you buy a coin mine it's
like an Xbox or a PlayStation that helps
you turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right you purchase it it shows up
at your doorstep you pull it out of the
box
you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide and
then you receive over-the-air updates
that add new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just you're updating
your coin mind consumer mining made easy
that's right go to coin mine comm tell
them tom sent you and thank me later
as many of you know crypto investors
store their digital assets on exchanges
or in cold storage for long-term
safekeeping however this strategy
doesn't help them grow their investment
holdings or build overall wealth with
the new block by interest account users
can now sick
early stored there Bitcoin or ether at
block five and received 6% annual
interest paid monthly and cryptocurrency
6% is an absurdly high rate it's the
best rate in the industry I highly
suggest you go check out block feiyr.com
slash pump again that's block 5 comm
slash pop to sign up and start earning
crypto today if you follow Bitcoin and
crypto
you've probably heard of eToro they're
the world's number one social trading
platform and I love it they've got more
than 10 million other traders that love
it too and guess what they just launched
the United States eToro offers access to
the world's most popular crypto
currencies including Bitcoin etherium
and others with the smartest trading
tools and the ability to connect with
the best trainers around the world
there's no better place to build your
perfect portfolio if you're new to
Bitcoin and crypto you can test the
waters with their $100,000 virtual
trading feature but if you're more
experienced you can create custom
technical charts and use eToro Social
Feeds to inform your trading decisions
they've got transparent fees and so you
never miss out they also have an
easy-to-use application available on
iPhone Android or any web browser you
can get started today in just a few
clicks
at each row calm again that's eToro comm
get VIP access to Bitcoin and crypto
markets today Anthony Pompano is a
partner at Morgan Creek digital all
opinions expressed by pump or his guests
on this podcast are solely their
opinions and do not reflect the opinions
of Morgan Creek Digital or Morgan Creek
Capital Management you should not treat
any opinion expressed by pomp as a
specific inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys bang bang I've got David
sitting here with me super excited to
record this episode I get tons and tons
of questions about tax treatment around
Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies so I wanted
him to come in and really just kind of
talk through what's going on in the tax
world and the product they've built and
how it can be helpful to people so
thanks so much for coming to do this
yeah yeah no thanks so much for having
me Tom it's good to be here
alright let's start with your background
obviously there's not that many
technologists who are excited about
so kind of what did you do pre Bitcoin
cryptocurrencies yeah
no you're exactly right so my background
I've always kind of had the
entrepreneurial feel so coming out of
school I kind of wanted to decide hey
what's the best way to apply you know my
background and get into more the
entrepreneurial world and so I went the
sales marketing route just thought
that'd be the quickest way right when
you look at building a company I think
the two most important things are you
know people who are building the product
or service and the people who are
getting it out the door so I wanted to
really specialize in distribution sales
business development and so got going
with a big software company worked at
Oracle doing sales for them for a while
and then ultimately made the jump into
entrepreneurship launched a card game
company that ultimately kind of took off
but it was like cards against humanity'
for colleges and universities so
ultimately got into some like legal
troubles with their you know IP
attorneys kind of coming after me so
after that kind of flamed out I got
really into crypto kind of fell down the
proverbial rabbit hole and started doing
some market making high-volume trading
and so with that we kind of ran into the
tax problem and so that's what
ultimately sparked the idea for crypto
trader attacks all right let's talk
about this this card game first of all
what was going on with this card game
yeah so so yeah so coming out of school
I saw a Kickstarter campaign for like
eight cards against humanity' version
but for like Harry Potter and it like
had destroyed its Kickstarter goals not
like oh that's like genius and I just
got all these wheels in my head going on
like how cards against humanity' gets
way more fun the more hyperlocal it
becomes so right the more and more
people can like immediately relate to
the content of the card game right and
so kind of wheels are going and I
thought the ultimate use case for that
is bringing it to like college campuses
where people you know live and die is
this intense college experience
and so I started essentially just
building a the card game right similar
to cards against humanity' but around
your college experience and all the
things that you do right when you're I
went to the University of Wisconsin
right when you're at Madison you know
whatever it may be and so launched that
and it just absolutely exploded again
getting back to like the distribute
distribution which is what I love and
what I'm really good at is marketing etc
and with that right everyone who buys
that card game it was called college
cards right they bring other people to
the game right so they buy it and then
they have to go play it with eight other
people and so naturally you get this
viral effect with this game and it
starts to snowball and we were selling
tens of thousands of dollars of this
card game at the University of Wisconsin
and so ultimately the University takes
notice to that and I got some cease and
desist from the law firms that represent
them but I expanded out to Michigan to
Ohio State University of Texas
ultimately had to shut everything down
after a long process but it was really
cool I thought it was my ticket to you
know building a really big business and
so I think it's interesting that you
look at it as the hyperlocal component
makes it more interesting
what was the give me some examples of
the things that were in the game right
so for University of Madison I have no
clue anything that's there but like what
were some of the things that were
actually part of the game yeah I mean it
was it was obviously very explicit
content and that was the point get
people like talking but it'd be like you
know getting your fake ID taken at the
KK which is you know a popular bar on
campus or like you know certain
professors write econ 101 with Elizabeth
Kelly so it was very very specific like
these inside jokes right that everyone
who went to Wisconsin would know the
Greek life played a big role right
making fun of certain sororities and
fraternities and so again whenever it's
this this hyperlocal you'll get people
tagging each other on Instagram posts
it's such like a Facebook social media
product and so just all that virality
built in it just it blew up but we we
ran into problems right where you you
the trademark people from Wisconsin even
though we weren't directly using any
official Wisconsin trademarks anytime
you're associating yourself with this
fool with those types of places you're
gonna run into problems so it's
unfortunate it left a bad taste in my
mouth just because you know it's a work
of satire we're not really taking
anything away from Wisconsin we wanted
to pay them a royalty but they wouldn't
even do that deal they just didn't want
the game to exist so it stopped swallow
but like ultimately blessing in disguise
because that led me to the world of
crypto got it and so you said that you
guys were doing like some market making
and stuff like that explain that a
little bit more yeah yeah so this is
back in 2017 and I sat down and had
dinner with a really good friend of mine
and he told me this interesting story of
his brother who was doing market making
on Finance so essentially writing you
know scripts and programs to automate
automate the trading for a lot of these
assets and he was making seventy
thousand dollars a month in 2017
so obviously like I was blown away that
I immediately call it my brother after
that dinner telling about my brother's
pretty technical and we decided to start
trying to build a market making BOTS
similar to what my buddy was describing
on Finance wasn't as easy as I thought
it might be but essentially what you're
trying to do is provide liquidity to
these you know exchanges which back then
very early on and you can just trade the
volatility of these assets and make the
spread right and you're it's a
high-volume strategy so we started doing
that we weren't like crazy sets we were
making some money this is really when
everything's starting to run up so like
we were doing well but not well enough
anyways though so the market making side
that's kind of how we got into it it was
ultimately just because I heard someone
was making a lot of money and so
ultimately as you're doing that there's
lots of transactions and you got to pay
taxes so I'm assuming that's what turns
you're under the tax problem well yeah
so I had no idea about the tax
implications of this stuff but keep in
mind I had just recently been burned by
the law from the card game so when I
found out about this it scared me and I
was like you know Michael who is my
brother I was like hey we have to
somehow be keeping a record of the US
dollar value of these
you know Bitcoin if you're in whatever
the asset we were in at the time of the
trade because that's what you need to
know to calculate the capital gain and
capital loss you know on the transaction
and in the world of cryptocurrency right
especially with exchanges like by Nance
about nothing's quoted in US dollars so
tracking that becomes seriously a
nightmare and so we ran in this huge
problem scoured the internet trying to
figure out you know how we how we fix
this there was nothing out there and so
myself and my two other partners not my
brother but we were all kind of doing
this together we kind of flip the switch
we're like this could be seriously an
infrastructural piece of this market if
it really does continue to expand right
like it or not taxes aren't going to go
away and I believe that you know for
crypto to reach mainstream and to kind
of expand its use case it has to play
nicely with the current financial world
and the current system and so you know
just flipping the switch we're like this
could be a really important piece so we
essentially build software to automate
the tax reporting process and you've got
no background in tax well so I studied
finance and accounting it at school I
was going to go into investment banking
and consulting decided not to but so in
that sense I have some but no I'm not
like a tax accountant or anything but
like to be fair this stuff is pretty
pretty simple right all right so let's
just start with kind of crypto tax 101
what are the aspects of the law that are
important to pay attention to and kind
of have a descriptive tax work today
yeah yep so crypto tax being the actual
law itself right yeah so I think the
easiest way to break it down just
because it's much more relatable for
people is comparing it to the world of
stocks because crypto currency like
stocks by the IRS is classified as
property for tax purposes and so what
that means is when you're selling or
disposing of your cryptocurrency right
when you're trading it whatever whatever
maybe you're incurring capital gains and
capital losses right and that's the same
as is the world of stock trading right
so let's run through a quick
alright let's say I buy $100 of Apple
stock right people are very familiar
with this type of thing and let's say
two months later that investment has
appreciated now that same Apple stock
that I bought is worth a hundred and
fifty dollars and I cash out let's say I
sell that Apple stock well from that
transaction I've incurred a $50 capital
gain right and I will a percentage of
that gain in taxes and so that's where
capital gains taxes people who are
familiar with equities with property you
know real estate they're familiar with
the world of capital gains capital
losses and so what a lot of people don't
understand is cryptocurrency is treated
the exact same way but because of the
transferable nature etc with
cryptocurrency some additional
challenges arise when it comes to tax
reporting I was kind of getting into
them right when I was talking about the
finance example but so let's look at a
cryptocurrency example let's say I again
buy $100 of Bitcoin with coinbase okay
and you know again two months later
let's say now that bitcoin is worth five
hundred dollars right I've made some
money and let's say I cash out on
coinbase make that five hundred dollars
well I have a four hundred dollar
capital gain and I lower tax on that and
so the tricky part with so that at a
high level right that's how it works
the tricky part with crypto is the
different taxable events that trigger
these gains or losses so again looking
at the world of stock trading what
actually triggered my gain was when I
sold my Apple stock right in the world
of crypto disposing of property your
cryptocurrency
can be you know when you're selling it
for fiat currency also though when you
trade it for another cryptocurrency and
this is where kind of the challenges
arise because let's say I bought that
Bitcoin for $100 it appreciated five
hundred dollars but let's say I didn't
cash out and I instead exchanged it all
for aetherium so that triggers a taxable
event like I realized my 500 my $400
gain in that Bitcoin and I also need to
pay a tax on it and as I'm sure you can
kind of imagine that right crypto de
crypto triggering taxable ends makes
the situation more sticky and
challenging from a reporting and
compliance standpoint yeah so part of
this is just that there's when it gets
treated as property there's certain
elements in the tax code that make this
much much more complex than it kind of
historically has been when it was just
an investable assets like a stock etc
and so one of them is crypto - crypto
right so what you think is hey I'm not
selling my Bitcoin I'm just simply
trading my Bitcoin for a theory of them
cuz I want to use that for something and
let's say that you're not even
speculating on price you're literally
just using the the digital asset that is
still a taxable but event because in
kind of my new show you've sold Bitcoin
you've bought etherium raise how the tax
treatment is on top of that even when
you go to sell that Bitcoin it may not
execute in one single transaction right
it could get broken up into six separate
transactions in order to sell it and my
interesting is that that's also taxable
event mmhmm yeah exactly so that's
that's all that's all correct other
taxable events right and this stuff is
annoying right because obviously
cryptocurrency is a lot more you know it
takes on so many characteristics right
it can be this form of digital money it
very much
is an investment that people are
speculating on it's also you know a
utility tokens right there's there's so
many use cases so it is challenging that
the IRS blanketly treats everything as
property but that is how it's handled
right now what do you think it'll take
to change that kind of guidance right in
terms of today they treated all his
properties there's something that you
see coming down the pipe or or some kind
of inflection point that would make that
evolve into some other guidance mhm yeah
honestly not really so the one thing
that I think would be cool honestly I
don't think it's going to happen my team
has a lot of conversations with a lot of
people very close to the IRS one thing
that I would think would be cool would
be to implement like a de minimis tax
exemption where you know the first
15-hundred dollars of capital gains is
tax-free and you don't need to be
necessarily reporting that because then
you know if I'm using Bitcoin to buy a
TV
or to purchase some goods or services
then I don't necessarily necessarily
need to be tracking my capital gains or
losses if it's up to X threshold now to
be clear that's not how it's handled
today right all of these things do
realize your gains or losses in the
asset other things that I think would be
cool in the future and again I'm not
sure how likely this is but if the IRS
actually explicitly came out and said
and didn't blanketly cover everything
Retton it was like hey for stable coins
which are designed to be a medium of
exchange right these shouldn't be
triggering capital gains and losses
every time you transact with it right
that's just a nightmare for businesses
for retail investors it's unfortunate
that it's treated that way but if you
know they actually classified separate
assets differently right Bitcoin for
example that's always want to be
property to many people use this as an
investment right I think pop you're
you're very much bullish on it as an
investment and so that's always going to
be have income associated with it and
therefore capital gains capital losses
but for the stable coins especially red
that shouldn't be treated as property
because it's designed as a medium of
exchange but for the IRS to have to
actually classify that they would have
to seriously like come out and say hey
this is a form of currency which I don't
think they're willing to do got it and
so obviously this is gonna be super
difficult for the individuals who are
transacting in this stuff right but they
rely on experts in accounting and tax
right so whether it's lawyers
accountants etc I can't imagine that
those folks are experts at
cryptocurrency tax treatment etc because
they're just doing so much other stuff
what are you seeing in kind of the
expert help vertical right where I'm
some individual I'm a business I need
help with my taxes I go to my account
and I go to my lawyer how the curve are
they and educated on this stuff versus
are they kind of just shooting in the
dark and really they just need as much
help as they can get yeah that's a great
question
so have you listened to podcasts all I
do is great questions
so honestly there is a huge lack of
supply in tax professionals accountants
enrolled agents who are familiar with
this stuff so with that lack of supply
right means the demand is exceeding
supply meaning the tax professionals who
are very comfort with us can charge it
very large premium on servicing this you
know lack of supply and this high demand
in the market so we're seeing that start
to change but yeah like you said the
vast majority of tax professionals of
accountants have no idea how Bitcoin how
aetherium how whatever it is is treated
from a tax perspective and when their
client comes to them right when they
have a collateralized debt position with
maker Dow and they're you know getting
interest payments and they say how do I
treat this where my taxes you know the
accountants gonna run away very quickly
we're seeing that start to change right
a lot of firms are actually starting to
build an entire tax practice around
crypto B's it's a great Avenue for
client acquisition right now right if
you can have on your website hey we're
familiar with crypto you're gonna get a
ton of clients right now just because
again there's not much supply but
there's a ton of pent-up demand
especially as the IRS starts you know
increasing awareness about how this is
tax enforcement etc but yeah you hit it
the very the vast majority of
professionals out there have no idea how
this is treated from a tax perspective
got it and so what did you guys build to
solve this problem yeah so a great
question
so we built crypto trader dot Tex is the
application that my team that's a great
name first of all thank you all right so
what does it do yeah the name is it was
very much an SEO play just trying to
game Google uh-huh so yeah so the the
high level pitch is we built the the
software automates the entire
cryptocurrency tax reporting process and
we're very much focused on the consumer
so you can frame it up in your mind like
a turbo tax for cryptocurrency investors
now I will say we also built tools for
tax professionals for exchanges etc but
really what it does is it allows someone
to land on our platform we integrate
with all major exchanges and
cryptocurrency platforms so they can
suck in all of their transaction history
into the platform
with the click of a button right and
once everything is into crypto trader
dot tax then they can generate their tax
reports for the year with the click of a
button
so it really automates the entire
capital gains capital losses reporting
so that you as a cryptocurrency investor
or user or enthusiasts can then just go
plug this report into your TurboTax
account into Tax Act or just give it to
your tax professional so they don't have
to know anything about how crypto stacks
how to do it how to do these
calculations they can just file that
form like they're used to with stock
trading and how easy is it for you guys
to interface with the exchanges like are
these API is pretty sophisticated and
built out or there's kind of a lot of
customization you have to do for each
one you know that's I get a funny
question because I mean it's so
drastically different across the board
like working with coin bases API is
awesome right they have great team there
but I mean there's problems with it too
like there's certain things there's bugs
in their API but it changes so much
across the board and that's one of our
biggest challenges is there's no
uniformity across these platforms and
exchanges and so from my team standpoint
we have to dive into every single API
every you know specific exchange and
build out that integration from scratch
so to answer the question there's no
uniformity but we take that onus from
the user right and we make it easy then
once you're actually in our platform
skirt school want to know who has the
best URL crypto comm that's right
crypto comm they're a crypto platform
with one goal mother mass adoption
that's why we're all here we're trying
to get crypto in every wallet crypto
calm is helping people do that through
buying earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto calm
go help your boy out
tell them pomp sense you download the
app or visit crypto comm pumps got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
pops gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mine it's like an Xbox or a PlayStation
that helps you
turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right you purchase it it shows up
at your doorstep you pull it out of the
box you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide and
then you receive over-the-air updates
that add new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just you're updating
your coin mind consumer mining made easy
that's right
go-to coin mine com tell them Tom sent
you and thank me later
one more word from our sponsor blocked
by their new interest account allows you
to securely deposit your Bitcoin or
Ethernet block by and receive six
percent annual interest paid monthly in
cryptocurrency this rate actually
compound so you receive a 6.2 percent
APY which is very attractive given the
alternatives so you can actually take
your Bitcoin you can deposit it with
block Phi and get paid an interest rate
of 6% in return go check out block v
comm slash pump again block v comm /
pump to sign up and start earning
interest on your crypto today got it and
so after I come to your website I sign
up
I go off you into my accounts you suck
in my data you kind of do all your
analysis what do I get
it's kind of the the end product of this
yeah so you get an entire tax report and
that contains a lot of things number one
it contains a breakdown of all of your
capital gains and capital losses short
term long term in the fiat currency that
you transact and so that's really
important right everything's going to be
denominated in u.s. dollars and that's
with our historical engine that we've
built we can you know the software will
go back and retrieve the price of
Bitcoin on July 13 2015 at 3:13 p.m. and
we can get that data down to the minute
so it's extremely accurate reporting
from a u.s. dollar perspective but for
in terms of what the output you'll
actually get you'll get IRS form 8949
which is your capital gains and losses
statement that you need from a tax
reporting perspective you'll also get a
complete income report we call it which
details let's say your cryptocurrency
miner let's say
you're getting staking rewards are you
running a masternode right that's
treated as ordinary income right not
necessarily capital gains losses and so
we'll break all that down automatically
in US dollar terms right so a digestible
income report again then you can just
give this to your accountant plugging
into TurboTax we also give you a
complete audit trail report which
details every single taxable event that
you incurred and exactly how we landed
on that calculation so let's say the IRS
ever does come knocking at your door you
can just give them this audit trail and
show and show them hey this is exactly
how I calculate the taxes on every
single taxable event
here you go sift through it a number of
other things but those are the main
things so that's the output right you're
getting an actual report that then you
can go file yourself you could easily
give it to your tax accountant or you
can easily plug it right into turbo tax
or tax act got it and then how do you
guys make money yeah so we it's
completely free to get started with our
software so you can jump in import all
of your trading history get in all of
your income make sure everything looks
good right we don't want to put up a
gate right in front of just getting so
getting start is completely free but we
make money when you want to generate
your tax reports which here in the US is
typically once a year so the regular you
know user will come to us generate all
their tax ports and pay anywhere from
$50 to $300 to download their entire tax
report for that year so it's not like
your typical subscription or
software-as-a-service right where it's a
monthly fee we're just a one-time a year
you generate reports you pay for it and
then you're good to go got it and then
how do you think about the evolution of
the business right today you guys are
super focused on crypto taxes are there
other areas that you're eyeing in terms
of where you could potentially expand in
the future or we just kind of go deeper
in in the tax protocol yeah so right now
the immediate areas are of expansion is
actually international expansion and
then a number of other things going
deeper in the current market we operate
in but so for example capital gains
capital losses are treated very
universally right now there's some
nuance but you know for example in
Australia they pretty much treat this
stuff exact
like the US does so from the technology
that we've built we can almost
immediately serve another market and so
we just launched Australia this past
summer we're rolling out Canada and the
next month we'll go to UK here before
the years over an international right so
we just need to tweak the logic of the
software to account for slightly
different variations of the rules right
that slightly different things but it's
all the same right it's your trading
this stuff and you're making money and
so that is a form of taxable income so
that's the immediate and to is to go
deeper in the current market so I'm sure
you know there's so many different use
cases of crypto you know margin trading
shaking shaking all this stuff you know
it's all income right it really is
people are using this to generate income
whether that's you know these new dphi
services where your interest from loans
right the block by guys I know all this
stuff is taxable and it's all
challenging because again nothing is
typically quoted in the USD it lives in
these fragmented places and so we can go
deeper in the market by further
servicing your margin traders lending
platforms defy so there's a lot to go
after and it's kind of you know get your
get your roots planted in the core and
then just blow it up from there so those
are the two really big focuses got it
and how similar are the tax guidance in
these other countries right so in terms
of capital gains capital losses that are
the same but is a Bitcoin and
cryptocurrency treated as a property in
all these other countries or you see
kind of a wide variety of treatments
yeah so in the in the vast majority its
treated very similarly and that that
means it's treated as property it's
treated as this investment now there's
some one off countries where they've
said hey we're not even gonna tax
capital gains and losses Portugal for
example there's some other ones that are
but the majority are treating it very
similarly to the US so yeah now again
there's there's slight variations for
example Canada you're required to use
average cost basis as you're costing
method which is kind of getting into the
minutia of actually doing the accounting
for capital gains capital losses but he
in the u.s. typically you're using first
in first out last in first out or like
highest in first out to optimize you
know or minimize your taxable gains but
yeah it is actually honestly treated
pretty similarly
like I said Portugal's a little bit
different there's some other countries
that we don't service at this point but
treat it a little differently
got it and then how about businesses
right so we talked a lot about kind of
crypto traders themselves but how do you
guys see the the corporate customers or
potential customers and and how they're
kind of interacting with this tax cuts
especially when let's say for example
they're just receiving Bitcoin because
their customers are paying with it
what's going on there yeah so in that
example you just gave that's pretty
straightforward right it's still just a
form of income right that this these
businesses would be receiving if they're
being paid in Bitcoin and again the
income they're recognizing should just
be the fair market value of Bitcoin at
the time they they receive it now where
things get really complex and I feel bad
for is the exchanges that operate in the
US and the actual companies that are
very much crypto native companies just
because they have an enormous set of
rules regulations that they need to
comply with right and and you know we
don't you know so like for example I if
you're a considered a money transmitter
you have to you know come fly with
FinCEN you have to do all these things
right and that's why you see a lot of
exchanges leaving the US because the
cost of doing business and complying is
tough now again we don't we don't
service that but from a business
standpoint that's challenging now where
we do work with exchanges and we have a
bunch of partnerships with them is you
know all of their users right
cryptocurrency exchange users platforms
they have this tax reporting problem and
the exchange themselves actually
fundamentally do not have the ability to
give their users capital gains and
capital losses forms which is this
fundamental problem in the space that a
lot of people don't have a handle on and
I like to explain it's this like user
expectation versus
reality problem because a lot of
cryptocurrency users right perhaps
they're used to you know going to a
typical stockbroker or brokerage house
like an e trade or a Charles Schwab or
you know a betterment thread all these
kind of FinTech type things where that's
where they're doing they're investing
their stock trading you know whatever it
might be and at the end of the year
right that Charles Schwab or e Trade
gives them a 1099 B write a tax form
that they can go and file with their tax
return right and on that form it breaks
down everything they need to do their
capital gains and capital losses
calculations and tax professionals are
used to getting a whole bunch of these
right from their clients that they plug
into their software turbo tax for
example is used to just you know letting
you import these 1099 B's from the
Charles Schwab and the e trades right to
automatically do this but crypto
currency exchanges fundamentally cannot
provide this type of form and that's
because of the transferable nature of
crypto so let's run through example
because it's really interesting to wrap
your head round and it's this huge
problem in the space so I love to
compare two stocks and that's just
because they're treated very similarly
from a tax perspective so again let's go
back to you know the Apple stock let's
say I buy Apple stock in Charles Schwab
and I do some investing buying selling
over the over the year right at the end
of the year Charles Schwab can give me
that form that shows hey David bought
Apple stock had $100 we're seeing that
he sold it at a hundred and fifty we're
seeing that then he went into you know
Tesla sold at XYZ right and all these
are broken out to me on the form that
they give me at the end of the year but
cryptocurrency changes cannot do this
and that's because it the data is so
fragmented and I can I can send Bitcoin
into my coin based wallet or into my gem
and I wallet from wherever right and so
coin base right
they don't have an entry in their
database as to what price I originally
bought that Bitcoin for right so they're
just saying that point zero five one two
three four right Bitcoin appeared in my
coin base wallet that's why
the entry gets entered in their database
but they have no history as to what my
cost basis in that Bitcoin is meaning
what I actually spent to acquire it and
so at the end of the year they can't
give me a capital gains in capital
losses report because they have no idea
the original price I purchased and you
know you can imagine this gets so
complicated because people are sending
wallet - wallet all the time they're
pulling it down into cold storage
they're sending their income they've
made from a mining rig right into the
exchange to go cash out etc and so the
end of the year comes around and the
users are so accustomed to being able to
just download their tax or tax forms
from their provider and you know the
exchange like well we can't really do
that sorry so the onus falls completely
on the consumer and they're kind of left
high and dry and again that's just
because of the nature of cryptocurrency
because this stuff can be transacted and
sold and sent from wallet - wallet that
the exchanges themselves cannot provide
this form and so that's the solution
right that's the problem that we solve
with crypto trader tags got it and so as
you see and talk about these forms the
IRS is now asking every American whether
they've actually traded crypto currency
or not talk a little bit about this yeah
so this was crazy
so I mean the past month has honestly
been probably the the busiest from a
crypto currency tax standpoint and again
that's because the IRS released its
first guidance in the past five years
technically it's the second one they've
released but source update to the
original 2014 tax guidance on
cryptocurrency this in October we were
in October 2019 for those listening two
years from now and two days after they
released that guidance they also
released a draft of the future 1040
which is the standard income tax form
that every single taxpayer in America
fills out and on this draft that they
sent out to all the tax software
companies and the big accounting
organization kind of prepare for it they
sent these out on that form
there is a checkbox that you know under
penalty of perjury now every single
American taxpayer which is roughly 150
million we'll have to check yes or no to
the question did you buy sell transact
or obtain any financial interest in any
virtual currency and so as a taxpayer
you know throughout the year and so as a
taxpayer you will have to check yes or
no and so this is just blowing open the
floodgates of you know awareness you
know the media outlets are going crazy
over this it's just really crazy and so
you have to answer your answer that it's
its newly on this new 1040 that everyone
have to fill out all turbo taxes and Tax
Act will have to ask their customers now
hey did you ever transact in virtual
currency this year and so we're just
seeing you know compliance from that
perspective just go through the roof I'm
actually more shocked not so much about
the irfs in that question but that only
150 of the 325 million Americans pay
taxes yeah well I mean if you think
about it's like so many people filed
jointly and if if you're like under
you're not actually filing your own tax
return so like these are individual tax
returns it's that's 150 million got it
okay and and so where do you see this
all going the kind of moving forward
really what are you excited about over
the next 12 months yeah well so
obviously this is really big for you
know our company at crypto trader dot
tax just because we're doing a lot of
educating in the market and that also
comes with you know the tax
professionals and accountants like I
said majority of them really have no
idea what's going on in this world so
you know that's a big focus for us is
educating those folks you know bringing
them software tools to help make their
world easier as they serve a bunch of
clients and as they now go and ask their
clients if they've ever transacted with
this type of thing so we're excited
about that and then I think we're also
just excited about making the world of
crypto investment you know transacting
in it easier and so you know
all this taxed off tax talk can leave
like a bad taste in your mouth
I get it I don't like paying taxes
either but you know we received hundreds
of chats on our customer support lines
from our users who are like hey you guys
made this so much easier
I was literally dreading this for months
I'm like so I'm so comfortable staying
and trading in crypto because I know I
can just you know generate my reports
simply and stay compliant and it's about
making it easier and so I'm excited
about that because you know anytime you
can make transacting and operating in
this world of crypto easier you you
allow more mainstream more people who
are not as technical comfortable in the
asset class and we're really seeing you
know with this guidance with all this
IRS activity you know they're validating
this asset like drill this is going to
be on the IRS 1040 schedule one that's
like I said filled up by 150 million
people and that's validating this market
right we're not seeing any slowdown in
in the market I think it's gonna keep
exploding and again I'm excited just to
make the tax reporting this ugly not
sexy process super easy for people
that's what I'm sorry for sure before we
get into the rapid-fire questions where
can people find out more and kind of
find the product and learn more about it
yeah so you can find us at crypto trader
dot Tex that's probably easiest way if
you want to reach out to me it's David
Kammerer and you probably easiest way is
just on LinkedIn David Cameron all right
rapid-fire questions what do you think
it's the most important company encrypt
other than your own who probably one of
the exchanges I'd say probably coinbase
sitting here in the US what they are
doing is pretty impressive what's the
one regulation that you would change or
improve if you could either the
accreditation laws where you know you
have to have X Net Worth to participate
in a lot of this not crypto stuff but
just in general or the IRS ruling around
how hard
Forks are taxed I think it's kind of
short-sighted
and I would just more treat it as a zero
cost basis and not as income when you
receive it what's the most controversial
thought you have in crypto so that what
you say it people will via bitly
disagree with you know hmm I'm still not
sure where a lot of this is going and I
think you know in crypto you get so many
people who are so sure that bitcoin is
going to be you know the reserve
currency of the world and like I
challenge that I'm still not sure it's
not gonna go away I can tell you that
but yeah I'm not sure as to how this is
all gonna play out but it's gonna be a
good ride for sure so basically the the
upside like what it how far up is the
ceiling to some degree figure that's my
question you're saying yeah that's
basically how you think yeah yeah
exactly it's like this isn't gonna go
away but like what is then what's the
upper limit right because it's so often
compared to the Internet and right
looking at how far that has become and
it's like I'm not a hundred percent sure
still it can do that we'll see there is
so many exciting use cases and sometimes
I'll flip-flop back and forth between
that some days I'll be oh wow this could
become like absolutely enormous you know
looking at specific use cases like I
love what the guys that like brave and
basic attention took it are doing I
think that's awesome I think that really
gets me excited when you're talking
about a way to monetize your own data so
yeah I mean I contradict myself but it's
hard to see as I'm sure you can agree
right ultimately where it's going but
maybe you disagree no not at all what um
what do you think is the most important
book you've ever read yes so I'm a
marketing sales guy and I'd say traction
by Gabriel Weinberg that's like an
awesome framework what is that about its
it breaks down essentially every
traction channel that a business can use
to market or distribute their product
and so you know he breaks down like I
think it's like 18 in the book the 18
different ways you can market
or distribute your product and once you
have that wide framework for each
business the traction channels that are
you know optimal for that certain
business change right so for the the
card game company was very social
focused and sharing right for the
company that I'm doing now it's very
content marketing heavy it's very search
engine optimization right all that stuff
so it just does a really good job of
breaking down every single traction
channel you can use to market your
products and then figuring out what
which ones should I use for X business
that I'm in today if you had to pick the
most important book for someone in
crypto what would you pick
probably the Bitcoin standard I think
why I think it's just again a good
fundamental it'll get you just thinking
about money you know why we think these
US dollars in our pocket have value and
ultimately challenge your perspective
there all right before I end each
episode I let you ask me one question
but uh aliens real not real oh yeah you
believe yeah I definitely think so I
actually like took an astronomy course
way back in college and you learn about
like the Drake Equation where you're
kind of like just the sheer probability
about it right how many planets out
there are circular or orbiting stars at
you know a habitable zone and there's
like zillions of them so I think just by
that when I was in when I was in high
school there was nine planets like that
was it Pluto was one of them but now
there are way more than nine what one
question you have for me to wrap this up
yeah okay um I want to know who I want
to know
what do you want today I want how you
actually cuz I don't know this how did
you originally get into crypto through
mining start building mining facilities
I saw they're very similar to data
centers this no-brainer to me the data
center is a pretty good business to be
in its infrastructure you don't really
care kind of who's successful who's not
you just want as much data going through
the room pipes as possible with mining I
was very similar I really didn't care so
much about the price because it was a
cash flow based business right so as
long as my cost to mind is lower than
the cost of whatever I'm mining I'm
pretty good business and so got started
there and then fell deeper and deeper
and deeper down the rabbit hole until
somehow now we have this podcast so do
you still mine
yes not quite as much as I used to but
what's gotten more competitive I'd
imagine it's got more competitive and
also it's a it's a game of incredible
capital right so it's just really
capital intensive and for me it's like
hey look do I just buy Bitcoin or do I
buy equipment to that in mine Bitcoin
there's pros and cons to each strategy
and so I do a little bit of both so not
not too bad where are where do you live
in case you want to meet up in person
yeah yeah so I'm located in Austin Texas
so if you're in Austin yeah feel free to
hit me up we feel like there's lots of
bitcoiners and crypto there's a longest
down there ya know it's a really good
community there's a lot of us it's
tight-knit just Texas in general
actually you know Dallas there's a lot
of folks too and so yeah I'm in Austin
Texas
awesome man alright well thank you so
much for coming to do this and then
we'll have to bring you back around tax
season to remind everyone pay the
[ __ ] taxes yeah thanks for having me
Matt hey everyone
pop here if you like this episode of off
the chain and want to help us take
crypto to the top of the Apple Spotify
and other podcast charts please do us a
favor and rate review and subscribe to
review simply go to the off-the-chain
homepage scroll down until you see the
five blank stars taking 15 seconds to
fill those stars in and leave a quick
review goes a long way in helping us
take the entire crypto ecosystem to the
top of the charts I appreciate you
listening and see you next time on off
the chain